[Music]
many are already eagerly awaiting the
upcoming Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania there are good reasons for
this as Kang the mcu's new super villain
will be making his feature film debut a
trailer was also shown for the first
time at the d23 Expo revealing many
details about the upcoming flick which
is why we will now discuss the
eyewitness accounts of those who got to
see the still unpublished trailer
protagonist Scott Lang AKA Ant-Man is
now married to Hope Van Dyne AKA wasp
and lives his life as a successful book
author also Scott's daughter Cassie is
not inactive because thanks to her
technical Talent she has built a
transmitter capable of sending signal
waves into the subatomic world of course
the project goes wrong and so Scott
Cassie hope and also Hank Pym are pulled
into the subatomic realm there they meet
King the Conqueror who succeeds in
capturing Cassie using her as leverage
he tasks his father Scott with stealing
something from that subatomic realm at
this point many are unsure exactly what
might be so important that Kang wants it
so badly Scott refuses after which king
reveals very shortly why he's the
perfect new villain in the MCU he easily
knocks the Avenger into a wall Kang also
asked Scott whether he has killed him
before as after all he is an Avenger and
they all blur together after a while so
it seems to be no big deal for King the
Conqueror to kill an Avenger we look
forward to seeing the trailer in its
entirety soon and are excited for the
upcoming Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania which is set to hit theaters
on February 17 2023.
foreign
[Music]
thank you